[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este especial del
debate de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález el 2020 será recordado por
obvias razones por la pandemia del cob y
19 y las múltiples consecuencias que
trabajo para la humanidad
este hecho que los tomó por sorpresa en
muchos sentidos pero esto no impidió que
el acontecer siguiera su curso las
noticias y los hechos destacados
siguieron teniendo lugar pese a que
estábamos mucho más atentos al tema de
la pandemia en este especial del debate
hablaremos de esos otros hechos que
fueron noticia que tuvieron cubrimiento
otros no tanto a lo largo de este año en
argentina hemos hecho una selección de
cuatro temas que se pasó a presentarse
los a continuación en este programa
entonces vamos a hablar de la
refinanciación de la deuda argentina y
el plan económico que tiene el gobierno
también hablaremos de la polémica
votación en la cámara baja del congreso
sobre la interrupción del embarazo
hablaremos también en un tema
medioambiental los incendios forestales
que afectaron a varias provincias
argentinas y por supuesto la muerte del
futbolista
armando maradona
para analizar y conocer detalles sobre
estos temas hemos invitado así la vil
querella es analista de opinión pública
también es investigadora magíster en
comunicación y cultura además es
directora de 3.0 y también bueno ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de buenos aires
también nuestro siguiente invitado se
encuentra de la capital argentina
ignacio labaki él es analista político
de la universidad católica de argentina
y también de la universidad del cema
ambos como ya decía se encuentran en la
capital argentina les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales se las recuerdo estamos en
facebook y nos encuentran también en
instagram en twitter como france24 bajo
ese y arroba sant y luego la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 pues comenzamos
entonces con el primer tema de la agenda
que es la deuda y el plan económico y la
refinanciación de esa deuda que tenía
argentina que ha sido una de las grandes
cargas que han llevado a los gobiernos
argentinos recientes y comienzos
entonces
con la su opinión sobre este tema
económico sobre esta refinanciación de
la deuda como le cayó esto al gobierno
en medio de la crisis de la pandemia del
cobre 19 adelante
bueno hay un
[Música]
finalmente llegó un acuerdo para
bonistas privados yo creo que fue uno de
los aciertos que el gobierno pudo poner
en valor ese ese acuerdo por delante por
supuesto un desafío ahora con el cierre
y el acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional argentina vamos a ver
tiene un problema tanto de sus cuentas
públicas como en
en esta deuda que tiene por delante el
gobierno ha manifestado desde el primer
momento que su voluntad de pago pero
bueno a ver intentando buscar una
especie de equilibrio entre las
posibilidades de nuestro país
a las necesidades de los de los
acreedores pero también sobre todo el
costo humano y posible de esos acuerdos
de esos cierres y me parece que en todo
caso es uno de los elementos que
discursivamente al menos siguen estando
en el tapete por supuesto el acuerdo de
la deuda por venir no está desvinculado
de un plan económico no digamos y me
parece que todavía es en esta zona hay
hay algo para trabajar y una todavía una
incógnita que se presenta sobre el
horizonte no si ignacio y su opinión al
respecto recordemos que algunos
organismos internacionales y también
instituciones allá en argentina han
indicado que la caída económica de este
país para el 2020 será del 10.2 otros
dicen 10.9 por ciento
y prevé en una recuperación económica
para el 2021 del 4.9 por ciento pero sin
duda alguna la renegociación de la deuda
le da un respiro al gobierno argentino
por lo menos por estos últimos meses del
año que piensa usted haber la
reestructuración de deuda lo que hace es
patear hacia adelante la carga de deuda
que la argentina que no tiene acceso al
mercado internacional de crédito
básicamente desde que estalló la crisis
en 2018 yo hubiera ido a después tuviera
podido pagarla no la atendía estuvo
brevemente en default pero lo resolvió
rápidamente con la reestructuración no
es un alivio solamente para estos meses
yo diría que es un alivio para los
próximos años que argentina solamente
debe volver a servir intereses de deuda
recién en 2023 y amortizaciones de la
hablamos de la deuda en dólares bajo
legislación extranjera mucho más
adelante entonces eso es un alivio
financiero importantísimo al gobierno y
es un logro
dicho esto diría que el gobierno lo
capitalizó o bien lo gobierno esperaba
que el arreglo con la deuda calmará las
tensiones cambiarias y la verdad que no
fue el caso
y se llevó un arreglo con los acreedores
ha tenido que aplicar muchas más
restricciones en el acceso al mercado de
cambios incluso forzar una
reestructuración compulsiva yo diría del
sector privado endeudado en dólares en
el extranjero este canje que hizo el
gobierno argentino fue por 110.000
millones de dólares para muchas personas
como ustedes lo decían fue un punto
acertado por parte del gobierno del
presidente fernández pero usted lo dice
ignacio argentina sigue sin levantar
cabeza a nivel económico y siguen sin
hacerse o diseñarse políticas que
atraigan tal vez más inversión
extranjera vemos algunas empresas han
dejado el país a lo largo de este año y
el país volvió a caer en posiciones del
ranking de competitividad global está en
el puesto 36 de 41 naciones evaluadas
qué pasa con la argentina porque no
logran dar una percepción un poco más
segura para el inversionista
pero pasan varias cosas problemas
argentinas no arrancaron con este
gobierno ni que la anterior sino que si
no mira en los últimos 10 años la
prendida prácticamente no ha crecido y
la verdad que la pandemia agravó todos
estos problemas a diferencia de otros
países de la región que tenían la
posibilidad de hacer una política
anticíclica esté financiada por
endeudamiento o financiada por colchones
de ahorro que habían tenido en otros
años aprendida no tenía nada de eso no o
sea entre la crisis en la que se
encontraba argentina desde 2018 y yo
agregaría la situación de la pandemia y
la cuarentena extendida eso lleva a que
la argentina sea la segunda economía en
caer tan fuerte dentro de américa latina
la primera es perú si la memoria no me
falla ahora bien dicho esto me parece
que el problema de inversión está en que
detecta directo ver con cambios de
reglas no y con cierta inseguridad y
también con
en los controles cambiarios entonces una
economía que se contrae hay cierta
percepción de un clima adverso de los
negocios eso difícilmente fomenta la
inversión extranjera directa saber qué
hacer esa aclaración que estaba haciendo
ignacio esto no es una situación de
dificultades económicas para este
gobierno argentina ya viene desde hace
una década presentando muchos problemas
incluso la administración del presidente
fernández asumió en medio de una
profunda crisis con un país que ya
llevaba dos años de recesión económica y
uno de los indicadores que preocupa a
nivel internacional
sila es el aumento de la pobreza que ha
tenido argentina a lo largo de este año
independiente de la pandemia que esto
reforzó pues todos los indicadores
en todos los países por lo menos los
indicadores de aspectos negativos como
la pobreza por ejemplo este país como le
puede hacer frente a esta situación como
se percibe allá en argentina este
aumento de la pobreza en estos casos de
personas que han sido desalojadas de sus
viviendas han tenido que invadir predios
en los suburbios de buenos aires y que
sigue aumentando el hambre también
una teoría que en materia de opinión
pública es una cosa es el problema de la
pobreza que despierta fuerte empatía y
otro es el problema de las tomas de
tierras que me da la impresión o la
observación que me da la impresión que
con un asa mientras mediciones
claramente tienen un fuerte rechazo de
la sociedad entonces si bien son de
alguna manera dos caras de un mismo
problema y no son procesados con rodilla
con la misma vara o con o con la misma
con la misma empatía y con la misma
voluntad de lo mismo
y yo tengo la impresión de que argentina
todavía maneja una imagen de la pobreza
relativamente vieja no iam ágeda de 2001
con los saqueos aparecía esa idea de ahí
estaba muy presente la idea del hambre
como uno de los principales problemas en
los tiradores de eso que es la pobreza y
el hecho maldito del saqueo o la pobreza
y el hambre yo creo que hoy ese hecho
maldito viene en la forma
de la ocupación de tierras en esta forma
de amenazas la propiedad privada que es
una de las es una de las formas en que
también obviamente se manifiesta la
pobreza pero que ahí la lotería los
niveles de aceptación social empiezan a
cambiar el otro elemento preocupante muy
preocupante sobre todo pensado en el
largo plazo tiene que ver con los
niveles de pobreza que harina y el
segmento de edad más bajo no en los más
jóvenes donde los niveles de pobreza
prácticamente alcanzan el 60 por ciento
es decir seis décadas chicos seis de
cada diez chicos argentinos están por
debajo de la línea de pobreza por
supuesto que una de las cosas que hay
que decir al primer claro de esto
la pobreza medida como a través de el
ingreso y no a través de otras de otros
indicadores con lo cual lleva la
contracción de la economía la
fluctuación de la inflación de la
fluctuación de precios y la inflación
de alguna manera vuelven muy el gas por
concepto también de pobreza de todos
modos es un tema absolutamente
preocupante
donde la crisis estacional es una de las
caras pero no la única para ir cerrando
este tema este primer punto de la agenda
ignacio cuáles son sus perspectivas su
proyección para el 2021 en materia
económica para su país para argentina
bueno yo soy politólogo no o sea que no
hago cálculos de cuánto va a crecer el
pp y ni cuánto sanamente pendiente de
eso pero pero yo diría con tomar cuenta
en la proyección
y creo que todo está muy adaptado a una
cuestión que es básicamente todo si
quiere la vacuna si el hecho que la
argentina puede evitar una segunda ola y
que puede evitar tener que aplicar
medidas de aislamiento social preventiva
obligatorio cuarentenas que tiene un
impacto muy severo sobre la actividad
económica y también un impacto muy
severo sobre las cuentas fiscales este y
la otra es que el gobierno cuál es el
margen del gobierno para evitar un salto
discreto del tipo de cambio una
devaluación básicamente no digo creo que
ese es el principal problema y la
principal prioridad del gobierno por
motivaciones económicas y por
motivaciones propias la economía va a
rebotar sencillamente por el hecho de
que si comparamos ellos los meses de
medidas más duras en cuanto alejamiento
a restricciones a la circulación es
fueron el segundo sobre todo segundo
trimestre de este año 7 en el próximo
tiene trabajar un rebote lógico no los
negocios que estaban cerrados y que
hayan sobrevivido a grande han quebrado
van a abrir van a tener mucho más
actividad
o sea que básicamente por eso se espera
un rebote también hay factores externos
favorables uno de ellos es que brasil
que es nuestro principal socio comercial
se está recuperando más rápido lo que se
preveía también hay prisa ante las
materias primas eso le va a jugar ahora
al gobierno pero después está el tema
cambiario no este mantener el tipo de
cambio deslizándose muy gradualmente
tiene costos y el costo eso es
básicamente cerrar el acceso al mercado
de cambios pisar importaciones y eso
tiene un efecto colateral sobre la nivel
de actividad no se hay materiales que no
se consiguen porque no entran
básicamente o porque no tienen precios
no exportadores que por ahí demoran
exportaciones para no liquidar las al
tipo de cambio oficial por un tema de
que hay un tipo de cambio paralelo que
es mucho más alto no claro entonces esas
cuestiones que le pueden volver en
contra el gobierno
pasamos al segundo tema de la agenda que
tenemos previsto para esta especial fila
y es la interrupción del embarazo un
tema que está digamos sobre la mesa está
siendo debatido en este momento en
diferentes sectores del senado argentino
se espera una votación el 29 de
diciembre y este es un tema que en
cuanto a opinión pública divide aguas en
todos los sectores de la sociedad
argentina lo hemos visto desde el año
2018 cuando hubo una primera votación
ahora el proyecto viene por parte del
gobierno impulsado por el propio
presidente como ve usted a la sociedad
argentina haciéndole frente a esta
polémica ya esta posible legalización ya
claramente como decir es un tema que
divide en un mitin y te diría
prácticamente la sociedad argentina en
un todo también es cierto que no no
hemos estado
viendo en el último en el último tiempo
los niveles de
conmoción social por la discusión del
tema yo creo que el 18 del 2018 la
discusión que hubo de alguna manera fue
una especie de antesala para esta
discusión 2020 en el caso del gobierno
es cierto el gobierno de igual proyecto
forma parte de sus promesas de campaña o
de sus propuestas electorales así que en
ese sentido en la discusión en el debate
por el aborto es algo que de no haberlo
pero haberlo presentado hubiese tenido
un costo para el gobierno a un año que
ya era de por sí complicado por lo
económico y por lo por la por los
sanitarios no por la pandemia cuando
cual me parece que hay algo acá de
jugada seria exigida por el propio con
la propia base electoral del gobierno
esto por un lado por otro lado bueno el
proyecto ya tiene media sanción por lo
pronto lo que se sabe hoy
aprenderse nada que las costuras se
están también divididas en un todo
hoy se está hablando de unos 35 33 con
13 indecisos por ahí entonces me da me
da la impresión de que
todavía representa un misterio con un
final abierto
y también lo que estamos viendo que en
términos narrativas y relatos por parte
de la opinión pública bueno no no no no
se está viendo esa esa movilización tan
fuerte que se vio en el en el 18
ignacio como están entonces las cargas
allí en el interior del senado de cara a
esta votación que va a haber el 29 usted
como ya lo decía es politólogo entiende
un poco más cómo están las cargas
armadas y puede haber coaliciones y
puede haber de pronto partes de la
oposición argentina que de pronto avalen
esto cómo ve usted el panorama allí
bueno cuando se trata de esta clase de
temas en general
los legisladores tienen libertad de
conciencia entonces este es un tema que
divide
a las coaliciones tanto la evolución de
gobierno como a la principal coalición
opositora para una idea el jefe del
bloque de senadores no lo que principal
era una de las principales espadas
desde el oficialismo al senadores del
senador josé mayáns de formosa es un
opositor férreo a la legalización del
aborto sí y usted va a tener también
legisladores senadores opositores como
por ejemplo algunos de la vista y
tracción de buenos aires que votan a
favor y que son de la oposición al
gobierno saque es un tema que cruza
entonces hay obviamente hay cálculo
político hay convicciones digo hay
muchos senadores que tienen un trato que
tienen banca su banca en juego el año
que viene tal vez especulen con eso
puede haber senadores opositores que no
quieran que este proyecto salga con este
gobierno yo creo que una cosa que es
diferente a lo de 2018 y que puede ser
un factor clave si es el compromiso el
liderazgo no
en el 2018 el presidente macri habilitó
el debate si a pekín o no tenía y su
partido no tenía a su coalición no tenía
mayoría en ninguna de las dos cámaras y
dejó hacer básicamente no los ejercicios
del liderazgo para convencer a los
oficialistas díscolos desde ese momento
para que no fueran al recinto o alguna
cosa así y eso definió un poquito la
votación no ahora en este caso el
presidente si está comprometido y
supuestamente la vicepresidenta que
cuando esto se votó en el senado en 2018
voto a favor a pesar de que durante 12
años cuando era presidente y tenía
mayoría no y no movió un dedo para que
se aprobara digo en ese momento voto a
favor si ella se manifiesta a favor y yo
tengo la impresión de que ya está a
favor también de que salga esta ley yo
creo que esa ley sale si ignacio como ve
usted en caso de que esta ley sea
aprobada y que argentina entre a ese
selecto club de 58 países que en este
momento son los que tienen
legalizada las prácticas de interrupción
del embarazo que significa en materia
política en materia de leyes y de
derechos para argentinas aprobar esta
ley
bueno ahí depende del cristal con que se
mide para mucha gente digamos lo que
aquí llamamos los celestes esto
representa un retroceso es un avance
sobre el derecho a
a la vida eso lo que entiende la iglesia
lo que entiende lo que entiende el papá
que obviamente no debe estar muy feliz
con esto pero para otra parte de la
población y particularmente para
gente liberal para gente del movimiento
feminista esto es un avance en materia
de defensa de derechos la verdad que es
dentro de américa latina son muy pocos
los países que tienen legalizada la
interrupción del embarazo la
interrupción voluntaria de embarazos o
sea la atendida a pasar de ser miembro
de un club aún más selecto
así que es vivido de distintas maneras y
es un tema que como decía allí la divide
a la sociedad donde hay una mitad a
favor de hacer una mitad lo percibe como
que avanza para usar una palabra una
expresión propia de
su santidad juan pablo segundo es el
avance de la cultura de la muerte para
otras el avance de un derecho de las
mujeres que ha sido postergado durante
demasiado tiempo
chila y para usted desde el punto de
vista político para el presidente
fernández que es quien está impulsando
este proyecto de ley allí en argentina
que tiene muchas diferencias con el que
presentaron en el 2018 este tiene unas
condiciones como por ejemplo la
gratuidad del procedimiento para las
mujeres y garantizarles ciertas
condiciones médicas sin importar la
clase social de la que pertenezca o de
la provincia donde se encuentre sin duda
alguna que esto salga aprobado sería un
gran acierto para el mandatario teniendo
como antesala este difícil año 2020
primer año de gobierno de fernández que
le ha costado mucho y son más los
deberes pendientes que tiene que los
aciertos que ha tenido según las
evaluaciones hechas
sin lugar a dudas nosotros elaboramos un
relevamiento en el que consultamos sobre
el impacto sobre la figura del
presidente y sobre la adhesión al frente
de todos en la población argentina y
realmente tendría de no haberlo
impulsado y de no movilizar a la acción
disfrutado con esos ya tales ya sus
senadores
creo que habría una especie de castigo
por parte de sus electores nosotros
estimamos alrededor de cuatro puntos de
un enojo fuerte rayando en la pérdida de
adhesión
así que si efectivamente representa muy
importante un importante riesgo también
la otra cosa que es cierto es que por
parte de los sectores más comprometidos
con
con el nuevo con el nuevo derecho hay un
un reclamo que no tiene que ver sólo con
la conquista de este nuevo derecho sino
también con la demanda al poder político
de movilización de sus legisladores y
sus diputados un poco en la línea de lo
que planteaba el gimnasio de ese modo
las figuras como mayáns que te
planteabas un senador
un senador oficialista representan de
una manera un dilema para el oficialismo
sin lugar a dudas también es cierto que
la libertad de conciencia es algo que en
estos temas suele jugarse y suele operar
con fuerza no la otra cosa que también
es importante es que uno de los de las
leyes con las que viven es de alguna
manera
tratados o acompañados a este proyecto
tiene que ver con el acompañamiento de
lo que se llamó el proyecto de los mil
días que es el acompañamiento de las
madres que decidan
pero seguir con un embarazo aún en
condiciones de dificultades económicas
o de fuertes dificultades para afrontar
lo bueno un acompañamiento fuerte
durante los primeros tres años de vida
de el hijo pues esto es un capítulo de
esta agenda que tendrá un desenlace el
29 de diciembre cuando el senado
argentino vote y decida darle luz verde
o no a este proyecto propuesto por el
presidente alberto fernández en
argentina el aborto está permitido con
ciertas causales desde el año 1921 y es
penalizado a todas las mujeres y aquí en
aquellas personas que las ayuden a
practicarse un aborto de una manera
clandestina o fuera de lo que estipula
la ley entonces lo que permitiría pues
es legalizar en otros escenarios
posibles y como lo explicaba nuestra
invitada con un acompañamiento a las
madres y también algo que llama la
atención es la gratuidad del
procedimiento en paso al tercer tema de
nuestra agenda no podemos dejar de
hablar del tema del medio ambiente
es un tema que nos concierne a todos a
las condiciones que se están presentando
a nuestro planeta con los hechos
residentes y son los incendios
forestales que han afectado argentina en
los últimos meses a lo largo del 2020
las provincias de jujuy misiones
corrientes entre ríos la rioja catamarca
entre otras mantienen en este momento
justo cuando están pensando el verano
allí en argentina en el hemisferio sur
tienen focos activos y esto ha dejado en
evidencia las complicadas políticas
ambientales que hay en este país en
algunas provincias en algunos en algunas
ciudades y deja sobre la mesa
precisamente el cuidado ambiental allí
en este país suramericano ignacio sus
impresiones sobre el manejo que le dan
en argentina a este tema ambiental lo
vayamos también en el invierno esos
incendios en las sierras de córdoba como
viste la situación allí
bueno me parece que hay un tema
climático importante que es la niña y
que es un problema que escapa el
gobierno que determina que hay años muy
secos y otros años con más volumen de
lluvias este sería uno de esos años más
bien secos y digo desde ya que vemos
muchos focos de incendio que fueron con
origen intencional pero digo yo no lo es
diaria de algo que
escapa del gobierno digo el gobierno no
decide cuando cuando hay niños cuando
hay niños o simplemente toca este y ya y
creo que eso es un problema lo cual nos
da una pauta de algo el tema
medioambiental es prioritario pero su
manejo excede a un solo país no es algo
que digamos los problemas
medioambientales no reconocen fronteras
o pasaportes si ocurren y demandan
digamos no digo que lo de los incendios
demande coordinación con otros países
pero prevenir el cambio climático si
demanda de la cooperación a nivel
internacional es un hecho claro pero
tener planes de prevención y sobre todo
con fenómenos como usted menciona la
niña que son fenómenos que en otros
países han tenido previsiones sabiendo
que van a ser las condiciones de baja
humedad de altas temperaturas como está
sucediendo en argentina muchos países se
han preparado precisamente con políticas
para hacerle frente a esa situación a
eso me refiero
sila cómo ve usted entonces al gobierno
argentino
batería de dos o tres cosas
de hecho derivada derivado de estos
incendios hace poco salió la ley de la
ley de fuego
que tiene que ver con una una hipótesis
respecto de la intencionalidad y la
especulación sobre la
la compra y venta de tierras la ley de
alguna manera lo que hace es prohibir la
comercialización de tierras que han sido
lo que han atravesado incendios
estos fenómenos y me parece que de
alguna manera eso previene de las
regulaciones que también existen en
estos temas
esto coronados por otro lado los temas
exporte más ecológicos la agenda
ecológica la agenda medioambiental por
supuesto es absolutamente central es
parte de una agenda nueva es una agenda
que en materia de opinión pública en
argentina es empujada por los sectores
más formados y por los sectores jóvenes
pero te diría que no no ocupa la
centralidad de
de la imaginación política y de la
imaginación ciudadana en ese sentido me
da la impresión que la vigencia que
tiene la agenda medioambiental en el
país en los países europeos no es la que
tienen los países latinoamericanos o
países como el nuestro donde realmente
los temas ecológicos siguen estando los
temas elementales siguen estando a la
cola no han alejado o por lo menos en un
lugar
si la diferencia entre una política
ambiental entre los países
latinoamericanos y los países europeos
donde nos llevan mucha ventaja en muchas
políticas medioambientales américa
latina todavía le queda mucho por hacer
y estos incendios y muchos de ellos que
han podido ser prevenidos dejan en
evidencia precisamente las malas
prácticas y la falta de políticas para
hacer frente a este tipo de situaciones
me quedan pocos minutos para terminar el
programa y quiero hablar de la muerte de
diego maradona que es nuestro último
punto de la agenda pues no hace falta
explicarlo no hace falta decir quién es
un futbolista argentino y su muerte pues
también genera todo tipo de comentarios
allí en argentina y solamente los
argentinos pueden entender la magnitud
de la muerte de diego maradona ignacio
sus opiniones sobre la muerte de
maradona para el fútbol argentino se
cierra un capítulo de historia de oro
del fútbol de ese país suramericano como
lo ve usted
poderoso diría que si se cierra
claramente una etapa por más que
maradona estaba retirado desde el año
2000 2001 sellam ahora no me falla este
y la última que participó de una copa
mundial fue del 94 como jugador y el
2010 como técnico evidentemente a
cualquiera que le gusta el fútbol no
solamente los argentinos hoy ya que el
luto es compartido también con los
napolitanos
esto es como un hecho triste previsible
yo creo que por cierto estilo de vida
pero triste quien es dios y disociar un
capítulo para fútbol argentino chila su
opinión porque vimos estas imágenes de
este funeral multitudinario en la casa
rosada- las calles del centro de buenos
aires completamente colapsadas llenas de
personas porque genera tantas pasiones
en argentina diego maradona pese a haber
sido muy polémico y no vamos a discutir
sus capacidades deportivas porque
sabemos que era un excelente jugador
pero no dejó de ser polémico
pero justamente que yo creo que su
propio carácter
el polémico es parte es parte de su de
las distintas capas de sentido que hay
sobre la figura de diego armando
maradona que sin lugar a dudas
hay casas que tienen que dar con los
futbolísticos con la idea de héroes vos
pensar que maradona es exponente de una
clase social de la clase social más baja
y si no va a ser amado y admirado por
todo el mundo con lo cual su
singularidad su el tipo de vínculo que
estableció con la sociedad en general es
algo que ha marcado a los argentinos a
fuego con la cual lo que te diría es que
no hay acá únicamente una cuestión
vinculada a lo deportiva
yo creo que maradona como como figura
argentina también es exponente de una
época que también está cerrando su
puerta
me parece que tiene que ver con la el
ascenso social
la posibilidad de este
es a esa estrella
y me parece también que es exponente de
una época donde la sociedad argentina
era mucho más homogénea en el sentido de
que los argentinos todos en conjunto
compartíamos diría más fuertemente una
cultura y no estas culturas dichos
segmentadas que vemos hoy en día no
entonces me parece que su pérdida no es
sólo una pérdida para el mundo deportivo
sino para el mundo cultural para ella
para el adn argentinos rápidamente para
los dos porque me quedan pocos segundos
argentina es un país de ídolos lo hemos
visto a lo largo de la historia de este
país suramericano ahora entonces que
sigue para ustedes
si la mira en nuestro país
se discuten mucho si maradona o messi lo
que yo te diría es messi claramente
unido a lo deportivo pero lo que no
tiene es discursividad no digamos lo que
tenía a maradona era justamente esa
capacidad de palabras de haber dejado un
montón de frases que ahora forman parte
de nuestra cultura con frases tan
magníficas como la pelota no se mancha
y se relacionó con presidentes con jefes
de estado con mandatarios de diferentes
países y hablo de política muchas veces
ignacio rápidamente su opinión
bueno si nos quedan pocos ídolos y me
parece que tiene que ver con algo de lo
que mencionaba así la eso de esa
sociedad más homogénea con una movilidad
social ascendente y que me parece que
existe todavía en el imaginario tal vez
de gente de mi generación o más grande
pero que lentamente se está yendo digo
en los hechos esa sociedad de movilidad
ascendente yo creo que se terminó hace
un tiempo y bueno veremos que nos quedan
algunos ídolos todavía está charly
garcía todavía y que veremos
ignacio muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros y ustedes muchas gracias
por la sintonía y gracias y sigan con la
programación de france 24
[Música]